hi I'm Stephanie hey I'm Kyra today we
are drawing characters that we have
never seen before the based on each
other's descriptions do I trust you I
don't trust me trusting you not trusting
me I chose something incredibly obscure
but also simple okay I feel like mine is
simple and construction and that's
what's gonna be interesting is how the
details but first be sure to stick
around till the end of the video to find
out how you can enter for a chance to
win this Wacom Intuos tablet for all of
your digital drawing needs courtesy of
your good friends at welcome did you
know that your hair and nails continue
to grow after you die how is that
relevant all right so what character am
i drawing today alright so for you I
chose junk rat from overwatch no idea
who that is
yeah he's a junkie boy what are you
making me draw I'm making you draw a
comic book character from my era 1700s
stop it by the name of its spawn oh so
Stephanie what have you chosen for me to
draw you are going to be drawing razz
razz sputum from psycho nuts so what am
I gonna be drawing so I chose the most
obscure thing ever
I chose real from pero pero sparkles
that means nothing to me you are drawing
Shin Chan Shin Chan Chan Chan plastic
since and my boy Shin Chan who the hell
is didn't Chan so am i drawing today I
have a very special Pokemon for you
today Cody his name is garbodor the
garbage pokemon garbage in concept and
design and so give me an overall
description of junk rat so he's like a
human yeah he's an Australian dude he's
just like laffy and giggly he loves
destruction okay so he's chaotic evil
he's chaotic evil he's like chaotic
neutral
I gave me like an overall description so
he's shirtless he's got some pants on
he's like the Joker well he but he's not
clean like the Joker
oh okay chunk rat is like I was wacky is
he wild and wacky he's wild and wacky
with overwatch drunk right uses grenades
and stuff it's like a grenade launcher
his ultimate move huh
is that he has this tire it rolls around
and it
loads okay two more things I feel like I
have to tell you his hair's on fire
seriously kind of and he is missing two
limbs let me give you an overall
description of Spawn so you can start
drawing okay so we're gonna be drawing
at the same time yep it's gonna break
your brain
oh my brain is already not really fully
completed okay so give me a general
description of Rasputin yeah so he's
human
he's overall construction big head small
body long limbs very angular and his
design in the game he's what they call a
psycho nuts so he's going to summer camp
to learn how to be a psycho nut and
basically infiltrate people's minds all
right give me some where to start with
okay well first of all just so you know
he's like two heads tall so he's a very
small person yeah you squat it's a child
and his head it's like oh man it's kind
of like a B I'm sure somebody and
there's like hardcore shin-chan fans out
there screaming like his head's the
classic B shape or something you know
whatever they do oh you know it's that
this set that like being like Cartoon
Network character had that like Clarence
and everybody has oh oh I know what
you're talking about yes the Cartoon
Network face what's is rule look like
okay so you're gonna think of it's like
an alien teddy bear and the one thing
that I will give you is the eyes look
like they have the entire universe it's
like a galaxy I colorful tear berry
really cute kind of like Pokemon and
anime ish a spawn is if venom and
Superman went to like a goth party this
is getting more confusing because I'm
imagining a buff goth kid I mean if you
want to go into a story he's undead and
he gets his powers from a deal that he
made with the devil oh my god why'd he
do that did he die at one point he did
and he will use hell yep he used to be a
mercenary killed people for money and so
he went to hell and he made a deal with
the devil because he wanted to see his
wife one more time the devil being the
devil gave him like demonic superpowers
put him back on the earth but then wiped
his memory so he didn't know who his
wife was oh so that sucks yeah so here's
garbodor for you he's an amorphous blob
Pokemon great so really no not too much
defining he's sort of just
a mound so his pre-evolved form is a
garbage bag and as he evolved it looks
like the bag just kind of busts open
from the bottom like he got to fat with
stuff and so now like there's the top of
his mound is like a bag that's been
split open he's like a pyramid shape
blobby pyramid
what is sparkle sparkle para para
whoo-hoo whatever
so para para sparkles it's made by this
in the artist in Japan and it's used for
a lot of fashion and comics merchandise
it's just kind of like a like a mascot
character sort of thing I feel like it's
probably one of those things that I've
seen like a dozen times but I've never
actually like put a face or names you
know is it like in the kind of Sanrio
realm of character for sure very Sanrio
does he have any motives this guy what
do you mean you know how the motive of
spider-man is a spider and Superman is
an S
he doesn't really on his chest he has a
swath of a different color it's like a
logo or is it you know I don't tell me
make your choice I will draw what I
think spawns logo would be follow your
heart and its skull because God's love
human anatomy I don't know what he wears
but I'm gonna try my best I can give you
some basic description so he has like a
aviator helmet with some goggles I
remembered that okay I mean his basic
elephant is like a sweater a jacket and
pants
he has gloves this is character wear
anything she just nope naked okay so
have much to work with with your guy
he's a pretty simple character described
as much as you can as quickly a thought
he's got a red sweater his arms taper to
like really thin wrists same thing with
the legs legs just taper to like tiny
little kind of pointy feet and he's got
yellow shorts white socks on does junk
rat is he wearing shoes yes he's wearing
shoes is he wearing like boots oh you
know what one of his legs is like a peg
leg okay like it is is that one of his
so one of his missing limbs is one of
his legs as a peg leg but they're not
gone gone he's replaced them this is the
future right so your storyboard
revisionists on Muppet Babies which is
adorable um so do you feel like the
character that I've given you to draw is
kind of in that way
house definitely like you know we've got
Fozzie Bear on that show baby Fozzie and
you know he's super those kind of
animate should be proportioned same with
all the other characters they're all
very like two to three heads tall and
and big limbs and everything like that
so like I have probably been drawing a
character like this in some regard for
the last nine months that I've been
there so once you got his body down i'll
go into describing his horrendous
looking hands oh he his hands so one of
them is kind of coming out of like the
bottom of his body his right hand and
then his other one it's just like the
same thing but it's like near where it's
shoulder you would imagine it would be
in terms of Boggs they're kind of Luke
on his bowie Boggs is an account the
land of Boggs that I work on at BuzzFeed
one of them has these great arms for
squeezing things we're trying to
reference things that were more familiar
with so since we both work in animation
do you use a Wacom tablet I do yeah
actually we use some cheeks at work and
then I have a Cintiq at home that I
really into animation on so I've been
using yeah like welcome since I was
maybe like 11 or 12 like my dad wanted
to like get me in the digital art game
pretty early yeah I also have um a
Cintiq here at work and at home and yeah
I started really young with like looking
in clothes or something
mm-hmm and as soon as I went onto Cintiq
I was like I can't ever go back I think
if you're so good you just draw like on
the screen can I give you just one word
and you interpret it however you want I
mean I've already committed to this goth
you look maybe you ready I'm ready
spikes spikes mm-hmm does he have spiky
knuckles you interpret that however you
want okay
I think spikes Jackie I'm gonna give him
spikes on his head
Oh you said there's nothing on it
there's nothing concepts I've already
drawn them
and the thing about drawing digitally is
there's no way to erase no there's no
way I've know where is away can someone
please let me know let us know in the
comments oh no I'm gonna tell you
something garbodor know about the
character I'm drawing less young as you
gave me the head details I think I might
know this character I think it's coming
to me so if you ever get amnesia and we
need to revive your memory we just make
you draw it you'll remember things that
you've seen before
is there anything that these little
characters first uh I will say they have
a tail that's like got a big poof ball
at the itis oh you know what he has very
very stubby feet at the bottom that are
just made of the garbage
oh they're like that purple he's at
grandmas yeah he's basically a garbage
grimace so I think I just threw venom
and goth clothes you're not far off
I don't like spun listen if you were a
dude like me in the 90s you were all
about spawn it's a good thing I'm a
woman like me in the 2010 and I love
instead dirty pyromaniacs
so I didn't make him dirty haha you have
time to make him dirty oh he's so filthy
that probably looks like a gentleman
yeah I think you did Cody this is one of
the most disgusting things I've drawn in
a long time yeah probably the grosser
the better this character is very cute I
think from what I'm remembering vaguely
in my head of this character if I do
know it I think this is accurate but it
was only because you gave me such a good
description how do you think you did I
think I did okay he looks like like a
little animal crossing' character but
how do you think you did I mean I heard
teddy bear and I just like this is what
I snapped to so I think it's that as
close as I could get it without seeing
oh no you kind of did it you did it
oh my gosh it's passable shrimp and a
disgusting blob Pokemon it turns out he
can be described effectively ha okay
this is not fun but I can see how you
got here from my description this looks
like Aquaman cosplaying junk rat why'd
you give him like an earring because
he's like a he's like a crazy guy are
crazy dude
wacky or watch this no like you
definitely Channel there really yeah
this is here ridiculously cute like
yours is very cute you definitely made
him a much more optimistic character
that I didn't he like he's just kind of
the boy you know he's a very aggressive
okay let's switch back okay Oh like blob
of stuff on her that's so cute
oh okay I get it
he's more shapes he's like a Picasso
painting it's funny that you even knew
to describe this as garbage because
without knowing his name like I didn't
even I don't even read that as like a
trash bag really is this just confusing
looking you know I did well Jackie okay
no I did you did okay Kevin you got much
closer mm-hmm then I did mm-hmm
it looks you know again if you squid
it's junk rat and you were kind enough
to give him a bag for all the stuff you
know the original designers didn't do
that
oh man okay yeah I got like some stuff
right like I care I'm just made that up
of a maze that I like kinda got the
color he has a striped shirt which I
it's sort of predicted mine is
definitely like baby version I feel like
my my version is like if you took the
design and made it Western yeah this guy
looks way more angry this guy just kind
of looks like his mom told him he
couldn't go to the concert alone mom
everybody else is cooing I'm the only
one who can't grow but I'm scoring mom
mom I'm spawning I have demonic powers I
can and will send you to hell if I had
to pick a person to describe things to
me we work together so much that I think
you were probably the right person to
describe our cartoon I've never heard it
to me so it was pretty easy I guess we
have more of a shorthand that we can
sort of draw on like I think referencing
other characters is very important it
was kind of cool to interpret what I was
not just like just try to fill in the
blanks yourself there's a nice like
creative flow that came from that this
is really fun I really like doing it so
the fact that I got closer than I
thought that I did I will say is a
compliment to your descriptive abilities
and you know what me getting really far
off is an insult to you
okay giveaway time if you want to enter
for a chance to win this Wacom Intuos s
tablet all you have to do is go to
BuzzFeed comics Instagram that's at
comics on Instagram find this post and
follow the instructions in the
description best of luck to you can I
get some pogs in the comment for this
giveaway others from Star Wars some Star
Wars yep completely I don't know
you